हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो प्लीज हमेशा की तरह
आज भी बता दीजिए। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
प्लीज चैट में यस या नो बता दीजिए। ओके?
और तब तक के लिए हम क्या करते हैं? कुछ
स्टूडेंट्स के ज्वाइन होने का वेट करते
हैं।
ओके वेरी गुड इवनिंग।
फिनक कोम एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग
नो एक्स ओके
ओके अच्छी बात है तो प्रीवियस क्लास से
रिलेटेड किसी का कोई डाउट है बताइए
प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड किसी के कोई
डाउट है जो कल की क्लास हुई थी उसमें किसी
के कोई डाउट है मैंने आपको स्क्रीनशॉट और
पीपीटी शेयर किए थे सबको मिल गए थे ग्रुप
में
पीपीटी और
आपको मिल गए थे। एक स्क्रीनशॉट कोड का मिल
गया था सबको
बताइए।
मिल गया था। अभी तो नोट्स की कोई शिकायत
नहीं है। प्रीवियस क्लास के जो नोट्स बचे
हुए हैं बिफोर क्लास 62
उनका भी मैं आप लोगों के लिए कुछ कर रहा
हूं। फाइंड आउट कर रहा हूं क्योंकि है
मेरे पास बट कौन से थे जो मैंने पढ़ाए थे।
थोड़ा सा समय दे दीजिए। वो भी मैं अपलोड
कर दूंगा वहां पर।
तो सबसे पहले मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता
हूं। एक इंपॉर्टेंट अनाउंसमेंट है आप सबके
लिए कि कल आप लोग जितने भी मेरे
स्टूडेंट्स हैं चाहे आप डीएजी के
स्टूडेंट्स हो आप नितेश सर के स्टूडेंट्स
हो शोक एनालिस्ट के स्टूडेंट्स हो वेरी
गुड इवनिंग एनोनिमस तो आप किसी भी क्लास
के स्टूडेंट हो खास करके डेफोनस एकडमी पर
तो आप लोगों के लिए बहुत ही ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट सीरीज स्टार्ट होने वाली है और
वो सीरीज सबके लिए है बाकी की तो उस सीरीज
में ज्वाइन होने के बाद आपको पता चलेगा कि
वो किसके लिए किसके लिए लेकिन वो सीरीज
सबके लिए मतलब सबके लिए है चाहे उसमें कोई
भी समझ लीजिए आप जो भी आपका सवाल है जो आप
सोच रहे हो सब में वो सब आ गए तो वो सीरीज
सबके लिए है तो कल शार्प 10 am आपको
मॉर्निंग में उसको ज्वाइन करना है और मेरी
आप सब लोगों से एक रिक्वेस्ट है प्लीज
डीएई की तरह मत करना क्योंकि वो सीरीज ऐसी
है ना उसके लिए आपको कुछ नहीं करना। बस
आपको अटेंड करना है। इतना ही है। उसमें
बहुत कुछ ऐसी नॉलेज आपको देखने को मिलेगी
जो नॉलेज कहीं नहीं मिलती आपको। तो जस्ट
आपको आपसे मेरी जो रिक्वेस्ट है मेरी
रिक्वेस्ट यह है कि आपको उस सीरीज को
ज्यादा से ज्यादा लोगों के साथ शेयर करना
है। चाहे कोई भी हो चाहे वह आपका नॉर्मल
एंप्लई हो किसी कंपनी का। मतलब आप वर्किंग
प्रोफेशनल हो कहीं पर भी इवन आप स्टूडेंट
हो तो यह सबके लिए है। यहां पर यह मैटर
नहीं करता कि आप साइबर सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट हो, शोक एनालिस्ट हो, पेंटस्टर
हो या है ये सब चीजें मैटर नहीं करती यहां
पर। तो मेरी आप लोगों से यही रिक्वेस्ट
है। तो उस सीरीज को सबके साथ शेयर कीजिए।
जहां-जहां पर आपके लिंक हैं सबके साथ शेयर
कीजिए। इवन आप अपनी फैमिली मेंबर्स के साथ
भी शेयर कर सकते हो क्योंकि उनको भी उससे
बहुत ज्यादा वैल्यूुएबल इंफॉर्मेशन मिलने
वाली है। ओके? तो मेरी आप सब से यही
रिक्वेस्ट है आप उस सीरीज को सबके साथ
शेयर कीजिए।
बाकी सीरीज में क्या होने वाला है और क्या
नहीं होने वाला वो कल एपिसोड वन आने वाला
है। शार्प 10 am बिल्कुल भी डिले नहीं
होगा। वह आप जैसे ही ज्वाइन करोगे आपको
पता चल जाएगा। उसमें क्या है और क्या नहीं
है सब कुछ पता चल जाएगा। तो चलिए हम अभी
सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं। ज्यादा टाइम
वेस्ट नहीं करने वाले। काफी स्टूडेंट तो
नहीं है बट ठीक है जितने आते हैं उतने आ
गए हैं।
तो भाई न्यू टेक्स्ट डॉक्यूमेंट
ये रहा हमारा कल वाला टेक्स्ट डॉक्यूमेंट।
सबको दिखाई दे रहा है यहां पर।
तो फिर से हम कंटिन्यू करते हैं
और एक काम कर देते हैं हम MS ऑफिस को भी
ओपन कर लेते हैं क्योंकि हमारा प्रैक्टिकल
सेशन है।
कुछ क्लिक करते हैं इसको क्लोज कर देते
हैं एंड वी विल गो टू डेवलपर टैब। गो टू
मैक और मैक में हम सेलेक्ट करते हैं डेमो।
डेमो। ओके? और उसके बाद हम सेलेक्ट करते
हैं दिस वन।
क्रिएट कर दिया। चलिए अच्छी बात है। नो
मैक्रो यह रहा हमारा। यहां पर हम इसको
क्या करने वाले हैं? यूज़ करने वाले हैं।
तो ये ओके फाइन ये विंड आपको दिखाई दे रही
है। तो चलो फिर हम चलते हैं अपने इसके
ऊपर। तो हमने wिप डॉट सेल जो आपकी अ
ऑब्जेक्ट था उसके बारे में पढ़ा था। और
उसका फर्स्ट मेथड था। कौन सा मेथड आपने
यूज़ किया था? फर्स्ट मेथड डॉट रन मेथड था
आपका। कौन सा? डॉट रन मेथड था उसके बारे
में आपने पढ़ा था। डॉट रन मेथड कहां पर
गया? ये रहा डॉट रन मेथड ये रहा। तो ये
डॉट रन मेथड का क्या था? एक सिंटेक्स था।
ठीक है? एसटीआर कमांड एडिट विंडो स्टाइल
या वेट ऑन रिटर्न। तो ये आप आपने
प्रैक्टिकली भी देखा था और आपको समझ में आ
गया था।
इट्स ओके। आई एम फाइन बडी। तो ये शायद आप
लोगों को क्लियर हो गया होगा डॉट रन में।
तो आज का जो हमारा मेथड है तो आज की जो
मैं डेट लिख देता हूं इसके नीचे आपको समझ
में आ जाएगा आज की डेट क्या है? आज की डेट
हमारी है
2 अगस्त 2026 की क्लास है। ठीक है? इसमें
हम क्या पढ़ रहे हैं आज? आज हम पढ़ने वाले
हैं क्या?
हमारा अगला नेक्स्ट मेथड। नेक्स्ट मेथड
हमारा क्या है? डॉट एग्जैक्ट मेथड। ठीक
है? आपका कौन सा मेथड है? डॉट एग्जैक्ट
मेथड। तो चलो टेक्स्ट की सी डॉट एग्जैक्ट
मेथड
डॉट एग्जैक्ट मेथड अब ये करता क्या है डॉट
एग्जैक्ट मेथड इज
यूज्ड व्हेन
यू
यू नीड टू रन यू नीड टू रन ए प्रोग्राम
एंड समलटेनसली
साइमलटेनसली
रीड इट्स
आउटपुट
और
ट्रैक इट्स
प्रोसेस आईडी ट्रैक इट्स
प्रोसेस आईडी जिसे हम पीआईडी भी बोलते
हैं। ओके
एंड क्या कंपेयर टू
एंड कंपेयर टू
डॉट
रन मेथड
एंड कंपेयर टू डॉट रन मेथड भी जीरो वाला
प्रैक्टिकल मैं आपको जल्दी दिखाऊंगा उसके
लिए भी हमारे पास अपकमिंग सेशन में क्या
है उस पर प्रैक्टिकल है
कंपेयर टू रन मेथड
इट ऑफर्स
मच मोर
एडवांस्ड कंट्रोल
एडवांस्ड
मच मोर एडवांस्ड कंट्रोल इसका मतलब क्या
है कि जो डॉट एग्जैक्ट मेथड है उसका यूज़
तब किया जाता है जब आपको किसी प्रोग्राम
को चलाने के साथ-साथ उसके आउटपुट को भी
रीड करना है। फॉर एग्जांपल आपकी आईपी
कॉन्फिग कमांड है। आपको प्रोसेससेस
कौन-कौन से रन कर रहे हैं? आपको मतलब आपको
टर्मिनल का आउटपुट रीड करना है। तो उस केस
में आप डॉट रन के बजाय कौन से मेथड का यूज़
करते हो? आप एग्जैक्ट मेथड का यूज़ करते
हो। या दूसरा कारण क्या है? आपको क्या
करना है? उस पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम की
प्रोसेस आईडी को ट्रैक करना है। जो भी आप
काम करना चाहते हो इस मेथड के मतलब कि जो
आप मैक्रो की हेल्प से तो उसकी प्रोसेस
आईडी को अगर ट्रैक करना है तब भी आप क्या
करते हो
डॉट एग्जैक्ट मेथड का यूज़ करते हो। ओके?
और इन अपोजिट जो आपका डॉट रन मेथड है वो
क्या है? वो
ये सारे काम नहीं कर सकता। मतलब कि जो डॉट
रन मेथड है उसके कंपैरिजन में डॉट
एग्जैक्ट मेथड एडवांस कैपेबिलिटी प्रोवाइड
करता है। एडवांस कंट्रोल प्रोवाइड करता
है। डॉट रन मेथड आपका क्या है? जो आउटपुट
है उसको रीड नहीं कर सकता। बस वो क्या कर
सकता है? उस पर्टिकुलर कमांड को
एग्जीक्यूट कर सकता है। लेकिन उसका आउटपुट
रीड नहीं करने वाला। ठीक है? उसका आउटपुट
रीड नहीं करने वाला। अभी इसका जो सिंटेक्स
की बात करता हूं। मैं आपको समझा देता हूं।
सिंटेक्स क्या होता है इसका? सिंटेक्स
होता है आपका। बाकी आप प्रैक्टिकली देखोगे
इसको। ठीक है? इसके सिंटेक्स की बात करें
तो सिंटेक्स में आपका रहता है
क्रिएट ऑब्जेक्ट।
जैसे कि आपको मैं सिंटेक्स बता देता हूं
सीधा। डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट डॉट सेल डब्लूsिप डॉट
सेल ये है डॉट एक्सक ईx ईc डॉट एक्सक उसके
बाद इसके अंदर आप एक पैरामीटर देते हो।
उसका नाम है एसटीआर कमांड। एसटीआर कमांड।
यह पैरामीटर आप इसके अंदर मेंशन करते हो।
यह पैरामीटर आप इसके अंदर क्या करते हो?
मेंशन करते हो। तो अभी इस पैरामीटर का
मतलब क्या है? तो डॉट एसटीआर इसके अंदर
क्या है? कि जो डॉट सॉरी एक्सट मेथड अंदर
जो ये पैरामीटर है ना एसटीआर कमांड इसके
अंदर आप कौन सी वैल्यू देते हो? स्ट्रिंग
वैल्यू देते हो। इसके अंदर आप क्या करते
हो? स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू देते हो। और इसका
मतलब क्या है? कि आप जो भी कमांड रन
करवाना चाहते हो जो भी कमांड रन करवाना
चाहते हो जिसका आप आउटपुट देखना चाहते हो
वो
स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू यहां पर देते हो उसकी जो
स्ट्रिंग की फॉर्म में उसको आप एसटीआर
कमांड के अंदर देते हो। मतलब ये पैरामीटर
है। इस पैरामीटर में आपको वो स्ट्रिंग
वैल्यू प्रोवाइड करनी है। आपको वो चीज
प्रोवाइड करनी है जो आप एग्जीक्यूट करवाना
चाहते हो। कोई पावर सेल का कोड एग्जीक्यूट
करवाना चाहते हो या कोई सीएमडी का कोड
एग्जीक्यूट करवाना चाहते हो। किसी
पर्टिकुलर कमांड को एग्जीक्यूट करवाना
चाहते हो जिसका आउटपुट देखना चाहते हो।
अंडरस्टुड यहां तक यहां तक सबको समझ में
आएगा कि मैं आपको क्या समझाने की कोशिश कर
रहा हूं कि ये इसका डॉट एग्जैक्ट मेथड का
सिंटेक्स है। इसके अंदर एक ही पैरामीटर आप
प्रोवाइड करते हो। वो पैरामीटर कौन सा है
आपका? एसटीआर कमांड जिसमें आप स्ट्रिंग
वैल्यू प्रोवाइड करते हो। स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू
में आपको आप वो वैल्यू प्रोवाइड करते हो
जिसको आप क्या करना चाहते हो? एग्जीक्यूट
करवाना चाहते हो। आई होप सबको समझ में आ
गया होगा। तो चलो फिर प्रैक्टिकली चलते
हैं क्योंकि हमें तो प्रैक्टिकली ही काम
करना है। तो चलो तो प्रैक्टिकली काम करने
के लिए चलो सबसे पहले मैं आपको प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन किसका दिखाऊंगा? सबसे पहले
मैं आपको डेमोंस्ट्रेशन दिखाने वाला हूं
आपके वैसे तो आपने कर चुके हो। तो सबसे
पहले हम प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
देखेंगे। किसका? आपके
अ डॉट रन मेथड का। क्योंकि दोनों में मैं
कंपैरिजन दिखाना चाहता हूं। तो डेमो
आपका
डॉट रन मेथड
ताकि आप लोगों को चीजें समझ में आ जाए
ताकि आपको समझ में आ जाए डॉट रन मेथड ठीक
है डॉट रन मेथड तो चलो ये आपकी कमेंट थी
कोई बात नहीं कमेंट हो गया अभी हम सबसे
पहले क्या करने वाले हैं एक ऑब्जेक्ट
क्रिएट करने वाले हैं ओबीj सेल ऑब्जेक्ट
हमने क्रिएट कर लिया सॉरी एक हमने क्या
क्रिएट किया?
मैं इसको एक काम कर देता हूं। अभी इसको
थोड़ा सा
टैब दे देता हूं। इसको भी इधर टैब दे देता
हूं। सबसे पहले एक वेरिएबल क्रिएट
डिक्लेअर कर रहे हैं। देन उसके अंदर हम
वेरिएबल के अंदर वैल्यू सेट करेंगे। ठीक
है? किसके? वही सेम सेट वेरिएबल ओ बी जे
सेल
सेम है। इक्वल हम क्या करें? क्रिएट
ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट
जैसा कि आपको पता है।
wsिप
डॉट सेल
wsिप डॉट सेल ये आपको पता है एक इंस्टेंस
क्रिएट करना होता है हमें किसका wsp डॉट
सेल का ठीक है wsिपॉट सेल का एक इंस्टेंस
हमने क्रिएट किया उसके बाद अभी मैं एक और
कमेंट देता हूं तो कमेंट में क्या है तो
आपको समझ में आ जाए एक कमेंट यहां पर क्या
है ओपन नोटपड
नोटपड नॉर्मली
नॉर्मली उसके बाद नेक्स्ट कमेंट किया गया
द स्क्रिप्ट
द स्क्रिप्ट मूव्स
मूव्स टू द नेक्स्ट लाइन
इमीडिएटली
विदाउट वेटिंग
विदाउट वेटिंग फॉर
यू टू
क्लोज नोटपड
यही है अंडरस्टुड इसका तो इसके लिए आपको
मुझे एक चीज बताइए मुझे क्या मेंशन करना
होगा अब मुझे क्या मेंशन करना होगा
हां मिश्रा जी आप अगर यह पूरी देख लोगे तो
आप बेसिक
जो आपको बिगिनर्स बोलते हैं जिसको आप सीएच
की तैयारी करते हो जब या ईजीपीटी की
तैयारी करते हो बेसिक पेंट जूनियर
पेंटेस्टर्स के लिए आप के ट्रैक पे पहुंच
जाओगे मतलब आपको पूरा आईडिया हो जाएगा कि
कैसे एथिकल हैकिंग परफॉर्म की जाती है।
कैसे पेन टेस्टिंग परफॉर्म की जाती है।
उसके बाद आपको तो फिर आगे बढ़ना है। आपको
एक प्रोफेशनल हैकर बनना है। एक प्रोफेशनल
एथिकल हैकर बनना है। तो आपको उसके लिए फिर
खुद से मेहनत करनी होगी। खुद से रिसर्च
करनी होगी। एडवांस कोर्सेस करने होंगे।
आपको बहुत सारी बुक्स पढ़नी होंगी। उसके
बाद बहुत सारी प्रैक्टिस करनी होगी। बट
यहां से आपके रास्ते खुल जाएंगे।
तो चलिए फिर अभी हम क्या करते हैं? बताओ
कैसे करेंगे? अभी हम कोई कमांड बताना
चाहेगा चैट में कि हम इसको कैसे करेंगे?
बताओ कैसे करेंगे हम?
बताओ कैसे करेंगे?
किसी को कोई आईडिया हम कैसे करने वाले
हैं?
बताओ कैसे लिखनी है कमांड मेरे को? कोई
बताएगा? नो यार ये गलत बात है। ओबीj सेल
शायद आप मेरी प्रीवियस क्लास में नहीं थे
तो इसलिए आपको नहीं पता। एबीजी सेल डॉट रन
उसके बाद आप क्या करते हो यहां पर नोटपड
exc नोटपड exc उसके बाद नेक्स्ट एंड हमने
वन मेंशन किया उसके बाद हमने लिखा फॉल्स
और ऐसा मत सोचो कि मैं आपको ये चीजें ऐसे
ही सिखा रहा हूं सर ये तो हमारे किसी काम
की नहीं है भाई हमें पूरे काम की है। अभी
आपके जो डेमोंस्ट्रेशन आएंगे ना आपको पूरा
पता चल जाएगा कि मैं इसको कैसे यूज करने
वाला हूं। ठीक है?
ओके यह अभी सही है जो हमने लिखा यह सही है
तो अभी उसके बाद हम लिखते हैं मैसेज बॉक्स
मैक्सिस बॉक्स को कॉल करते हैं एंड देन
चलो भैया
नोटपड हैज़ बीन लॉन्च
सक्सेसफुल यूजिंग
डॉट रन
ओके
यह सही है कोड आपके सामने।
यह कोड सही है। यह सच बताओ कल किस-किस ने
प्रैक्टिस की थी। मुझे सच-सच बताओ कि कल
किस-किस ने प्रैक्टिस की है। मुझे नहीं
लगता सबने प्रैक्टिस की होगी। बट ईमानदारी
से बताओ कितने लोगों ने प्रैक्टिस की है?
आलोक कुमार हम क्या कर रहे हैं? क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स में हम वीबीए बेस्ड या मैक
बेस्ड पेलोड बनाना सीख रहे हैं।
मैक बेस्ड पेलोड बनाना सीख रहे हैं।
ओके? पेलोड बनाना सीख रहे हैं।
तो चलो फिर इसको रन करके देखते हैं। तो
आपको डिफरेंस पता चल जाएगा कि अभी इसको
मैंने रन किया। ठीक है? चलो
नोटपड ओपन हो गया। और अब आप ध्यान से
देखोगे तो ये किसी का इसने वेट नहीं किया
होगा।
यह रहा नोटपड हैज़ बीन हैज़ बीन ल्च यूजिंग
Dr. नहीं वेट किया। नोटपड भी ओपन हो गया।
बट इसका किसी ने वेट किया। नहीं वेट किया
ना वही है। तो चलो भाई हम नोटपैड को ओपन
क्लोज कर देते हैं। भैया इस नोटपैड की
हमें जरूरत नहीं थी। इसको ओके कर देते
हैं। चलो तो यह चीज सबको पता है। अब आते
हैं हम हमारे एक्चुअल कोड पर जो हमें क्या
करने वाला था? हम पढ़ने वाले हैं। तो
एक्चुअल कोड पे पढ़ने के लिए हम इसको क्या
करते हैं? पूरी तरह से अभी कर देते हैं
डिलीट। भैया यहां इसको कर देते हैं डिलीट।
इसको डिलीट नहीं करेंगे। हम इसमें क्या
करते हैं? और वेरिएबल डिक्लेअ कर देते
हैं। तो एक और वेरिएबल डिक्लेअ करता हूं
मैं। ऑफ सेल के अलावा हम एक और वेरिएबल
डिक्लेअर करेंगे। कौन सा?
ओबीj एग्जैक्ट
ओबीj एग्जैक्ट उसके बाद एसटीआर आउटपुट
आउट पुट एसटीआर आउटपुट तीन वेरिएबल हमने
यहां पर डिक्लेअर किए। फर्स्ट वेरिएबल को
हमने यहां पर यूज़ कर लिया। फर्स्ट वेरिएबल
को हमने यहां पर यूज़ कर लिया। तो उससे
पहले हम क्या करने वाले हैं? इसको मैं
क्या कर देता हूं? अभी के लिए इसको कर
देता हूं खत्म। डिलीट। ठीक है? तो फर्स्ट
वेरिएबल को यूज़ करने हम यहां लिखते हैं एक
मैसेज बॉक्स। मैसेज बॉक्स
देन मैसेज बॉक्स में हम लिखते हैं डेमो
रनिंग
आईपी कॉन्फिग
कॉन्फिग यूजिंग
ओबीj
सेल डॉट
एग्जैक्ट
टू कैप्चर आउटपुट
कैप्चर आउटपुट
तो कैप्चर आउटपुट
हो गया ये आपका कैप्चर आउटपुट उसके बाद हम
क्या करने वाले हैं सबसे पहला हम यूज़ करने
वाले हैं एक और वेरिएबल तो चलो फिर एक और
वेरिएबल यूज़ करते हैं सेट सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी
सॉरी कहां आ गया भैया सेट कीवर्ड का यूज़
यूज़ करने वाले हैं सेट कीवर्ड। तो उसके
बाद हम यूज़ करेंगे ओबी जे एक्सक
ये मेरा एक वेरिएबल हम क्या करना है यहां
पर ई एक्स ई सी यहां पर हम अभी यूज़ कर रहे
हैं तो चलो फिर ओबीजी सेल
डॉट एक्सक
डॉट
एक्सटॉx
में यही है उसके बाद इसके अंदर मेंशन करते
हैं हमें जो कमांड रन करवानी है तो IP
कॉन्फिग
IP कॉन्फ़िग यह कमांड हमें क्या करनी है?
यहां पर रन करवानी है। IP कॉन्फ़िग OBJSL.x
एक्सक्ट एक्स ईc ओके राइट नाउ उसके बाद एक
और मैसेज बॉक्स हम यहां पर क्या करते हैं?
वो करते हैं। तो चलो मैसेज बॉक्स
नेक्स्ट हम यहां पर फिर लिखते हैं
सक्सेसफुली।
प्रोसेस आईडी
डॉट प्रोसेस आईडी ठीक है देखो मैं ओबीj
एक्सक डॉट प्रोसेस आईडी क्योंकि यहां पर
हम क्या कर इसको खोल ओबीj एक्सक उसके बाद
प्रोसेस आईडी ठीक है उसके बाद प्रोसेस
आईडी यहां पर मेंशन करते हैं।
प्रोसेस आईडी ओके ये मे बी ये भी आपको समझ
में आ गया होगा। यहां पर हमने क्या किया?
ओबीजी एक्सक्ट डॉट प्रोसेस आईडी यहां पर।
ओबीजी एक्सक्ट के अंदर आपको क्या है? ये
रहा जो आपने आईपी कॉन्फिग कमांड रन की है
किसके अंदर? सीएमडी के अंदर उसका उसकी एक
प्रोसेस क्रिएट हुई होगी। तो उसकी यहां पर
प्रोसेस आईडी आप क्या कर सकते हो? रीड कर
सकते हो। उसकी प्रोसेस आईडी आप यहां पर
रीड कर सकते हो। चलो ओके। नेक्स्ट एक डू
वाइल लूप इसमें रन करके दिखा देता हूं
आपको। मैंने पढ़ाया नहीं था। बट डोंट वरी
आप सिंपल है। डू वाइल उसके बाद हम क्या कर
सकते हैं? ये रहा
ओबीj एग्जैक्ट
डॉट स्टेटस टी ए टी यू एस स्टेटस इक्वल
ज़ीरो
अगर ज़ीरो है तो नेक्स्ट आपको क्या करना
है?
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट
डब्लू स्क्रिप्ट
स्क्रिप्ट डॉट स्लिप
डब्लू स्क्रिप्ट डॉट स्लिप ठीक है आप 100
लिख सकते हो ये सारे इसके इनबिल्ट है इनका
आप यूज़ कर सकते हो उसके बाद लूप
उस नेक्स्ट हम यूज़ कर रहे हैं अब एस टीआर
आउटपुट
आउटपुट क्योंकि सेल एक्सप्लनेटरी है आपके
डू व्हाइल उसके बाद ओबीजी उसके एक स्टेटस
वो प्रॉपर्टी को कॉल किया कंपेयर किया
क्योंकि जो प्रोसेस आईडी आ गया उसका ज़ीरो
आया ठीक है मतलब इसको कंपैरिजन किया हमने
आउटपुट अगर सही है तो देन उसके बाद एसटीआर
आउट पुट इक्वल हम क्या कर रहे हैं ओबीj
एक्सक
डॉट एसटीd
आउटपुट रीड करने के लिए हम क्या करेंगे
एसटीडी आउट
डॉट रीड ऑल फंक्शन का इसमें आप कॉल
करेंगे। ठीक है? ये वाला अगर आपको उस
पर्टिकुलर कमांड का आउटपुट रीड करना है।
उस पर्टिकुलर कमांड का आपको क्या करना है?
अगर आउटपुट रीड करना है।
आउटपुट रीड करना है। तो आप क्या करोगे?
ओबीj एक्सेक्ट क्योंकि ये आपका वेरिएबल
यहां पर डिक्लेअ किया है। उसके बाद एसटीडी
आउट मतलब स्टैंडर्ड आउट उसके बाद रीड ऑल
फंक्शन। तो यह आउटपुट का क्या करेगा? रीड
करेगा और इसके अंदर स्टोर कर लेगा। देन
उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं? एक और मैसेज
बॉक्स आपको क्लियर हो जाएगा।
मैसेज बॉक्स
कमांड आउटपुट
ये काम डॉट रन से नहीं कर सकते आप।
रिसीव्ड।
यह कैर रिटर्न यहां पर यूज़ कर रहे हैं हम।
एसटीआर आउटपुट ओके एंड ये रहा यहां तक जो
भी मैंने वेट वेट वेट वेट
ओके। एंड ऑफ स्टेटमेंट
हो चुका था। गुड।
तो यहां तक सबको समझ में आया? हम क्या कर
रहे हैं? यहां तक जो भी कोड हम लिख रहे
हैं सबको समझ में आ रहा है? ये कोड क्लियर
है आपको?
एक तीन वेरिएबल क्रिएट किए। इसके अंदर
हमने स्टोर किया आपका इंस्टेंस। उसके बाद
हमने एक्सेक्ट मेथड को यूज़ किया। उसके
अंदर एक कमांड दिया। आईपी कॉन्फिग उसका
आउटपुट हमें रीड करना है। उसके बाद उसकी
प्रोसेस आईडी देखना चाहते हैं। उसके बाद
यहां पर स्लिप क्यों कर रहे हैं? क्योंकि
तब तक जो आउटपुट है ठीक है? उसको रीड होता
रहे। ठीक है? वो रीड होता रहे। उसके बाद
ये देखो अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? इसको रन करें।
आपको क्या लगता है? रन होगा।
रन होगा। बताओ। कर रन इसको।
आर यू रेडी?
सब लोग रेडी हो?
चलो फिर इसको हम करते हैं रन।
चलो डेमो रनिंग आईपी कॉन्फ़िग यूजिंग ओबीj
सेल डॉट एक्सक्ट टू कैप्चर आउटपुट। इसको
हम सबसे पहले ओके करते हैं। ओके किया। ओके
किया। देखो एक छोटा सा पॉपअप आया था।
प्रोसेस स्टार्टेड सक्सेसफुली प्रोसेस
आईडी 13328 आ गई प्रोसेस आईडी। अगर आपको
देखना है तो देखो सीएमडी वैसे रन नहीं है।
टास्क मैनेजर पर चलते हैं हम। आपको पता चल
जाएगा यहां पर टास्क मैनेजर पर तो आपको
सीएमडी मिल जाएगी। अगर मैं यहां पर चलूं
तो वे म सीएमडी
कहीं ना कहीं सीएमडी की प्रोसेस आपको
मिलेगी इसमें नीचे। ठीक है?
आपको सीएमडी की प्रोसेस मिलेगी।
क्योंकि मेरे सिस्टम में बहुत सारी
प्रोसेससेस चल रही हैं। तो मे बी आई एम
नॉट एबल टू इतना जल्दी बट सीएमडी की
प्रोसेस आपको मिलेगी।
कंसोल विंडोज होस्ट एक ठीक है आपको
मिलेगी। आप देखोगे ना तो 100% आपको मिलेगी
वो चीज सीएमडी प्रोसेस आपको देखने को
मिलेगी और अगर हम देखें तो कहां पर मिलेगी
वेट वेट वेट वेट वेट
चलो इसको मैं अभी क्लोज कर देता हूं टाइम
वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे ठीक है और जैसे ही मैं
इसको एक काम करता हूं ओके करूं ये देखो
आउटपुट आ गया
ये देखो देखो ये देखो ये देखो Windows IP
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन सो और ये रहा कनेक्शन सफिक्स
ये है कनेक्टेड है ये है ये है मतलब आया
आउटपुट या IPपी एड्रेस है 192.16891
सो ये है तो जो हमें आउटपुट वो करना था
यहां पर आ गया
ओके और यहां पे आउटपुट आपके सामने आ गया
अगर फिर से रन करके दिखाऊं तो फिर से आपको
पता चल जाएगा
ओके ये आ गया आपका आउटपुट ये आपका आउटपुट
आ गया अब ये पूरी तरह क्योंकि हमने यहां
नहीं चाहिए आउटपुट हमें किसी फाइल में सेव
करना है तो वो भी हम देखेंगे इसका भी एक
प्रोजेक्ट है मेरे पास आप आपके सामने
करवाने वाला हूं तो ओके सबको समझ में आ
गया होगा यहां पर नेक्स्ट
ये सबको क्लियर है
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है
यह कोड यहां तक सबको क्लियर है
तो अगर यहां तक सबको क्लियर है तो नेक्स्ट
हम क्या करने वाले हैं
अभी नेक्स्ट क्या चीज यूज़ करने वाले हैं
हम इसके अंदर हम रजिस्ट्री के साथ कैसे
इंटैक्ट कर सकते हैं वो देखना आप सबको
रजिस्ट्री के साथ कैसे इंटैक्ट कर सकते
हैं आप सब लोग देखना चाहते हो तो वो भी हम
देख सकते हैं तो चलो फिर इसके लिए हम तीन
मेथड यूज़ यूज़ करते हैं तीन बेसिकली
रजिस्ट्री के अंदर एक तो डॉट रेज एडिट ठीक
है डॉट
रजिस्ट्री के साथ इंटैक्ट करने के लिए
हाउ टू
विद
Windows रजिस्ट्री
इसके लिए हम क्या करने वाले हैं? तीन मेथड
यूज़ करते हैं। सबसे पहला हम यूज़ करते हैं
डॉट रेड। सबसे पहला डॉट
आर ईजी रीड डॉट आर ईजी रीड इस मेथड का यूज़
करते हैं। सबसे पहला मेथड हम कौन सा यूज़
करते हैं? आर ईजी रीड। ठीक है? इस मेथड का
मतलब क्या होता है?
दिस मेथड इज
यूज टू
रीड
वैल्यूस
फ्रॉम द
Windows रजिस्ट्री
Windows रजिस्ट्री अंडरस्टुड?
ठीक है? इस मेथड का यूज़ किया जाता है
Windows रजिस्ट्री से वैल्यू रीड करने के
लिए। दूसरा मेथड हम कौन सा यूज़ करते हैं?
दूसरा मेथड हम यूज़ करते हैं
आर ईजी राइट आर ईजी आर राइट इस मेथड का हम
यूज़ करते हैं। यह मेथड किस लिए यूज़ किया
जाता है?
दिस मेथड
इज़ सॉरी मेथड की स्पेलिंग गलत होगी।
इज यूज्ड
टू क्रिएट
यूज टू क्रिएट और अपडेट
क्रिएट और अपडेट
वैल्यू चेंज द Windows रजिस्ट्री
Windows रजिस्ट्री। Windows रजिस्ट्री के
अंदर अगर आपको कोई भी वैल्यू अपडेट करनी
है, क्रिएट करनी है तो आप किसका यूज़ कर
सकते हैं?
आर ईजी राइट मेथड का यूज कर सकते हैं। एक
और मेथड कौन सा यूज़ करते हैं? थर्ड वर्ड
आपका डॉट आर ईजी डिलीट मेथड।
हम लैंग्वेज यूज़ कर रहे हैं वीबीए।
Microsoft Word एक्सेल आउटलुक मतलब MS
Office के साथ आपको इंटैक्ट करने के लिए
अगर कोई प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज यूज़ करनी
है तो आप वीबीए का यूज़ कर सकते हो।
बेसिकली वीबीए चल रही है। वीबीए पेलोड
डेवलपमेंट मतलब Microsoft Office के अंदर
कोई भी आपको पेलोड प्लांट करना है तो वो
कैसे कर सकते हो?
डिलीट मेथड
ओके ये आपका रजिस्ट्री डिलीट मेथड है।
मतलब ये क्या करता है? यूज़्ड टू डिलीट ए
की और वैल्यू फ्रॉम द रजिस्ट्री।
यूज्ड
यूज टू डिलीट
डिलीट ए की
और वैल्यू
फ्रॉम द रजिस्ट्री।
रजिस्ट्री से कोई भी वैल्यू डिलीट और
क्रिएट करने के लिए हम किसका यूज़ करते
हैं? इस मेथड का यूज़ करते हैं। चलो फिर
सबका अपना-अपना सिंटेक्स है। ये सबको पता
चल गया। तो सबसे पहले इसके सिंटेक्स के
बारे में बात करते हैं। इसका सिंटेक्स
क्या है? तो चलो फिर इसका सिंटेक्स क्या
है? सिंटेक्स के बारे में डिस्कशन कर लेते
हैं। भैया इसका सिंटेक्स क्या होगा? तो
सिंटेक्स के बारे में डिस्कशन करते हैं।
तो चलो
तो सिंटेक्स की बारी आती है। तो लेट्स डू
सिंटेक्स। तो सिंटेक्स में इसका जो
सिंटेक्स होता है सिंटेक्स होता है आपका
सेम। इस तरीके से क्रिएट ऑब्जेक्ट
यहां तक तो सेम है।
क्रिएट ऑब्जेक्ट डॉट डॉट आर ईजी रीड आर
ईजी रीड इसके अंदर आप जो पैरामीटर देते हो
एसटीआर
नेम एसटीआर नेम ठीक है? इसके अंदर जो आप
पैरामीटर देते हो एसटीआर नेम मतलब एक
स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू प्रोवाइड करते हो और इसके
अंदर द पाथ ऑफ द रजिस्ट्री की इस पैरामीटर
के अगर इस पैरामीटर की वैल्यू के बारे में
आपको समझना हो जो पैरामीटर है तो चलो एस
टी आर नेम
इसके अंदर जो आप वैल्यू देते हो स्ट्रिंग
वैल्यू
इसके अंदर वैल्यू आप प्रोवाइड करते हो
स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू
द
पाथ ऑफ द रजिस्ट्री फाइल
रजिस्ट्री की पाथ ऑफ द रजिस्ट्री की सॉरी
पाथ ऑफ द रजिस्ट्री की ये इसका सिंटेक्स
है ये इसका सिंटेक्स है क्लियर है
सिंटेक्स
इसका सिंटेक्स क्लियर है सबको
इसका सिंटेक्स क्लियर है नेक्स्ट सेकंड
सिंटेक्स कौन सा यूज़ करते हैं इसका
सिंटेक्स क्या है इसके बारे में बात करते
हैं तो चलो फज़ का भी सिंटेक्स देख लेते
हैं क्रिएट ऑब्जेक्ट के बाद में इसका
सिंटेक्स क्या होगा? तो इसके सिंटेक्स कुछ
इस तरीके से रहेगा। ठीक है? पहले इसका
सिंटेक्स और क्लियर कर लेते हैं। कंट्रोल
सी
एंड डेट क्लो ये इसका सिंटेक्स क्रिएट
ऑब्जेक्ट डब्ल्यूस्किप डॉट सेल डॉट राइट
आर ईजी
रीड राइट
रजिस्ट्री राइट। इसके अंदर आप तीन वैल्यू
प्रोवाइड करते हो इसके साथ। ठीक है?
बेसिकली आप इसके अंदर कैसे लिखते हो उसको
मैं आपको बताता हूं। देखो ऐसे नहीं
लिखेंगे अभी हम इसको ऐसे मेंशन करके दिखा
देता हूं। ये रहा सबसे पहले आप सेम कीवर्ड
लिखते हो एसटीआर नेम एसटीआर नेम उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट आता है आपकी कोई भी एनी वैल्यू
जिसके अंदर क्योंकि आपको चेंज करना है तो
यहां पर सबसे पहले एसटीआर नेम आप क्या
करते हो? रजिस्ट्री की का पाथ मेंशन करते
हो। एनी वैल्यू जो वैल्यू आपको क्या करनी
है? राइट करनी है आपको या अपडेट करनी है।
उसके बाद आप थर्ड पैरामीटर क्या करते हो?
एसटीआर टाइप एसटीआर टाइप तो चलिए फिर वेट
वेट वेट एसटीआर टाइप ये है। तो चलिए फिर
सबसे पहले हम इसी फर्स्ट पैरामीटर पे आ
जाते हैं। तो सेम ही है आपका ये आपका सेम
है। बिल्कुल पाथ ऑफ द रजिस्ट्री की। ये
आपका बिल्कुल सेम है। ये बिल्कुल सेम है
पाथ ऑफ द रजिस्ट्री की। नेक्स्ट आते हैं
हम।
नेक्स्ट आपका कौन सा पैरामीटर है? एनी
वैल्यू।
एनी वैल्यू इस पैरामीटर में क्या चीज
वैल्यू देते हो इसमें भी आप क्या करते हो
क्या देते हो एनी वैल्यू के अंदर एनी
वैल्यू के अंदर कोई भी वैल्यू ठीक है कोई
भी वैल्यू
वैल्यू ऑफ की वैल्यू ऑफ़ की
ओके वैल्यू ऑफ़ द की नेक्स्ट आपका क्या है
चलो ये रहा नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट हम यूज़ करते
हैं आपका एसटीआर टाइप। एसटीआर टाइप। तो
इसके अंदर आप क्या चीज मेंशन करते हो भाई?
इसके अंदर जो आप वैल्यू मेंशन करते हो वो
स्ट्रिंग मेंशन करते हो। इसके अंदर वैल्यू
भी स्ट्रिंग में आप मेंशन करते हो।
स्ट्रिंग में भाई क्या मेंशन करते हो?
स्ट्रिंग में आप तीन वैल्यू मेंशन करते
हो। ठीक है? तो पहली बात तो किस पर्पस के
लिए? इसके लिए जानते हैं हम। इसका पर्पस
क्या है? द
डाटा टाइप
इन द
रजिस्ट्री
की
रजिस्ट्री रजिस्ट्री में डेटा टाइप क्या
होगा रजिस्ट्री का जो वैल्यू आप स्टोर कर
रहे हो उसका भी तो कोई ना कोई डेट टाइप
होगा ना इंटीजर होगा स्ट्रिंग होगा कोई
हेक्साडेसिमल होगा न्यूमेरिक होगा तो वो
डेटा टाइप यहां आप मेंशन करते हो उसके
अंदर इसके साथ में स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू के
अंदर तो अब भाई वो कौन-कौन से डेटा टाइप
है यहां पर तीन डेटा टाइप आते हैं आपके
ठीक है यहां पर आपके तीन डेट डेटा टाइप
आते हैं। तो सबसे पहला कौन सा डेटा टाइप
आता है आपका? सबसे पहला आपका आता है आर ई
जी अंडरस्कोर एस ज
आता है आपका। ठीक है? ये डेटा का टाइप का
मतलब क्या है? स्टैंडर्ड स्ट्रिंग डेटा।
स्टैंडर्ड
स्टैंडर्ड स्ट्रिंग
स्ट्रिंग डेटा। स्टैंडर्ड स्ट्रिंग डेटा।
ओके? ये आपका स्टैंडर्ड स्ट्रिंग डाटा है।
नेक्स्ट आपका आता है। चलो फिर नेक्स्ट आता
है आपका आप मेंशन करते हो आर ई जी
अंडरस्कोर डी वर्ड
ओ आर डी डी वर्ड। ठीक है? ये डेटा टाइप आप
मेंशन करते हो। डी वर्ड इसका मतलब क्या
है? इसका मतलब आपका न्यूममेरिक इंटीजर
वैल्यू। आप कोई इंटीजर वैल्यू यहां पर
देना चाहते हो। न्यूममेरिक इंटीजर वैल्यू
रजिस्ट्री में ज्यादातर क्या है? इंटीजर
वैल्यू ज्यादा यूज की जाती है। न्यूममेरिक
इंटीजर वैल्यू आई एन टी जी इंटीजर
न्यूमेरिक इंटीजर वैल्यू। नेक्स्ट थर्ड
चीज आप क्या दे सकते हो? थर्ड आप वैल्यू
देते हो यहां पर आर ईजी अंडर बाइनरी
बाइनरी। कई बार टाइप हो सकती है तो आप
Google भी कर सकते हो। ठीक है? आर ईजी
बाइनरी यहां पर आप हेक्साडेसिमल
डेसिमल बाइनरी डाटा दे दो बाइनरी डेटा
मेंशन कर यहां पर इसके अंदर तो ये तीन
वैल्यू आप इसके साथ दे सकते हो बेसिकली
पहले रजिस्ट्री की का पाथ दूसरा उसकी
वैल्यू तीसरा उसका डेटा टाइप यहां पर
मेंशन करते हो ये इसका क्या है आपका
आरईजी राइट रजिस्ट्री राइट के लिए मेथड का
सिंटेक्स था ये सिंटेक्स क्लियर सबको ये
सिंटेक्स सबको क्लियर है?
ये सिंटेक्स सबको क्लियर है। तो एक काम
करते हैं। अभी नेक्स्ट मेथड के सिंटेक्स
पे चलते हैं। इसका सिंटेक्स क्या है भैया?
इसका सिंटेक्स भी बहुत बड़ा है। नहीं छोटा
इसका सिंटेक्स कुछ बड़ा नहीं है। छोटा ही
है। इसके सिंटेक्स की बात करते हैं। तो
चलो आ जाते हैं। इसका सिंटेक्स कुछ इसी
टाइप का है।
सेम इसी टाइप का इसका सिंटेक्स है। मैं
यहां पर कॉपी कर देता हूं। यहां पे लिखा
सिंटेक्स। उसके बाद देखो यहां पर लिखते हो
आप रेज डिलीट
डी ई आर एल ई टी डिलीट ओके उसके बाद ये
इसको हटा दो उसमें लिखने की जरूरत तो नहीं
थी पर हमने लिख दिया ठीक है ये रहा एक ही
पैरामीटर इसके अंदर आप मेंशन करते हो
एसटीआर नेम मतलब दी पाथ ऑफ द रजिस्ट्री की
जिसको आप डिलीट करना चाहते हो तो ये आपके
तीन मेथड्स हैं। ये आपके तीन मेथड्स हैं।
तो उसके बाद एक और है। एक और मेथड हम यूज़
करते हैं पॉप मेथड। वो भी बता देता हूं
आपको। डॉट पॉप मेथड तीनों को एक साथ
करेंगे। पॉप डॉट पॉप मेथड ये क्या काम
करता है? डॉट पॉप मेथड ये क्या काम करता
है? इसके बारे में जानते हैं।
हेक्साडेसिमल
वैल्यू हेक्साडेसिमल बाइनरी डाटा।
हेक्साडेसिमल को भी बाइनरी में कन्वर्ट
करके। ओके? वो होता है आपका। नेक्स्ट पॉप
मेथड क्या करता है? इसके बारे में समझ
लेते हैं। पॉप मेथड
दिस मेथड
इज यूज्ड टू डिस्प्ले
ए
कस्टम
विंडोज
डायलॉग बॉक्स।
ठीक है? आपको एक कस्टम विंडो डायलॉग बॉक्स
क्या करता है? शो करता है पॉप मेथड। इसके
नाम में भी पॉप है। तो इसका भी सिंटेक्स
क्या होगा? चलो भाई, इसके सिंटेक्स पे आ
जाते हैं। यहां तक तो सिंटेक्स सेम रहेगा।
तो यहां तक इसका सिंटेक्स भी सेम रहेगा।
उसके बाद लिखते हैं डॉट पॉप।
उसके बाद इसके भी क्या है? कुछ पैरामीटर्स
हैं। पॉप अप सॉरी ये पॉप अप है यार। पॉप
अप मेथड है ये डॉट पॉप अप है। सॉरी आई एम
स्पेल मिस्टेक ये पॉप अप मेथड है। ओके। अब
इसके अंदर आप कुछ पैरामीटर्स वैल्यू
प्रोवाइड करते हैं। तो सबसे पहला होता है
एसटीआर टेक्स्ट। एसटीआर टेक्स्ट। उसके बाद
सेकंड आप मेंशन करते हो n
डी n सेकंड्स
टू वेट
n सेकंड्स टू वेट थर्ड आप मेंशन करते हो
एस टीआर
टाइटल एसटीआर टाइटल
उसके बाद फोर्थ वन हम मेंशन करते हैं एन
टाइप ये सारे ऑप्शनल है वैसे तो क्योंकि
ये आप मेंशन भी नहीं करोगे तो भी आप क्या
है? ये आपके डिफ़ॉल्ट वैल्यू को उठा लेगा।
तो, इन चारों के बारे में समझते हैं।
चारों का मतलब क्या है? ठीक है? मेंशन
एक्सप्लेन करूं इन चारों का भी बता देता
हूं आपको ताकि आपको क्लेरिटी बनी रहे।
सबसे पहले आता है आपका एसटीआर स्ट्रिंग।
ठीक है? आपका सबसे पहला आएगा एसटीआर
स्ट्रिंग। ये क्या काम आएगा? चलो फिर एसटी
स्ट्रिंग पे आ जाते हैं। एसटीआर स्ट्रिंग
एसटीआर टेक्स्ट
सॉरी एसटीआर टेक्स्ट। तो इसके अंदर आप
स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू मेंशन करते हो। इसका यूज़
क्या किया जाता है? कब किया जाता है? द
टेक्स्ट
टेक्स्ट मैसेज
यू वांट टू डिस्प्ले
जो आप टेक्स्ट मैसेज डिस्प्ले करना चाहते
हो उस पॉपअप बॉक्स के अंदर। ठीक है?
इंसाइड
द पॉपअप
बॉक्स। उस पॉप अप बॉक्स के अंदर जो
टेक्स्ट वैल्यू आप पॉप अप करवाना चाहते हो
वो आप क्या करते हो? यहां पर मेंशन करते
हो। ओके? दूसरा n सेकंड टू वेट। ये इसका
यहां पर आप क्या मेंशन करते हो? चलो भैया
ये भी बता देते हैं यहां पर क्या मेंशन
करते हैं? इसके अंदर आप मेंशन करते हो
इंटीजर वैल्यू। इसके अंदर इंटीजर वैल्यू
आप मेंशन करते हो। ठीक है? अब इंटीजर
वैल्यू में यहां पर क्या मेंशन करते हो
आप? सेकंड के लिए। टाइम 0 1 2 3 4 ठीक है?
आपका क्या है? टाइम इन सेकंड।
आफ्टर वि
द पॉपअप
विंडो
विंडोज़
ऑटोमेटिकली
क्लोजेस। मतलब आप वो सेकंड मेंशन करते हो
जितने सेकंड के बाद वो जो पॉपअप मैसेज है
अपने आप में क्या हो जाए? क्लोज हो जाए।
अगर आप बाय डिफॉल्ट छोड़ देते हो तो जीरो
रहता है। जीरो का मतलब इनडेफिनेटली। ठीक
है? वो वेट करेगा। नेक्स्ट आपका आता है
आपका थर्ड वन। आपका थर्ड वन एसटीआर टाइटल
नाम में ही है। इसके अंदर भी इंटीजर
वैल्यू आएगी। सॉरी स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू
क्योंकि ये टाइटल की वैल्यू टाइटल के लिए
है। ठीक है?
टेक्स्ट
टू डिस्प्ले
इन द
टाइटल बार
ऑफ द पॉपअप विंडो
पॉप अप विंडोज मतलब पॉपअप के विंडो के जो
टाइटल बार में आपको टेक्स्ट शो करवाना है
प्र्प करवाना है वो आप यहां पर मेंशन करते
हो। नेक्स्ट फोर्थ वन आ जाते हैं हम।
फोर्थ वन हमारा क्या है? एन टाइप।
n टाइप इसके अंदर आप क्या मेंशन करते हो
इंटजर
इसके अंदर आप मेंशन करते हो इंटजर इसका
रोल क्या है कि आप कॉम्बिनेशन कॉम्बिनेशन
मतलब आपको बटन का कॉम्बिनेशन आप साथ में
शो करवाना चाहते हो कोई इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
जैसे यहां पर आप क्या-क्या यूज़ कर सकते हो
जीरो जीरो का मतलब आप क्या यूज़ कर सकते हो
ओके ओनली ओके ओनली ठीक है दूसरा आप यहां
पर यूज़ कर सकते हो वन वन का मतलब क्या है
ओके और कैंसिल
कैंसिल बटन आपको यहां पर दे अगर आप वो
करवाना चाहते हो शो करवाना चाहते हो जो
बटंस आते हैं उसके बाद अगर वैल्यू क्या दे
फोर दे सकते हो फोर का मतलब यस या नो बटन
आप शो करवाना चाहते हो या फिर आप दे सकते
हो 16
16 या बटन के लिए आप 16 वही आप आइकॉन कौन
सा यहां पर आएगा आपका क्रिटिकल आइकॉन
क्रिटिकल या आपका स्टॉप आइकॉन क्या होगा?
शो होगा साथ में। अगर 32 मेंशन किया है तो
आपका क्वेश्चन मार्क शो होगा।
क्वेश्चन मार्क आपको शो होगा। अगर 48
मेंशन किया है तो एस्केलेशन मार्क आपका
वार्निंग या
वार्निंग या एस्केलेशन
एस्क्लेमिनेशन।
ठीक है? एस्केलेशन मार्क्स स्पेलिंग गलत
हो सकती है मे बी एस्केलेशन
ई एक्स
ई एस
सी ई एक्स
ई एक्स सी
एस्कुलेशन मार्क्स ठीक है और लास्ट वन है
आपका 64 अगर आप इंटीजर मेंशन करते हो तो
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन ओके इंफॉर्मेशनेशन यहां पर
ये वैल्यू दे सकते हो वन ओके ओनली बटन ओके
और कैंसिल के लिए सॉरी जीरो ओके ओनली वन
ओके और कैंसिल के लिए फोर यस या नो के लिए
आपका 16 क्रिटिकल स्टॉप के लिए 32 48 ये
सारी आप वैल्यू्यूज यहां पर मेंशन कर सकते
हो। चलो इट्स ओके तो अभी इसका आपको मैं
प्रैक्टिकली एक प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
शो करने वाला हूं। ये शायद आपको पता चल
गया था कि हम यहां पर क्या-क्या मेंशन कर
सकते हैं। तो अभी हम इसका देखते हैं।
सिंटेक्स देख लिया। अब हम प्रैक्टिकल
हां ये सारे नहीं n टाइप में आपके सारे
कीवर्ड नहीं है। इसमें आप इंटीजर वैल्यू
मेंशन करते हो। ये रहा देखो मैंने क्या
बोला था? इंटीजर
इंटीजर वैल्यू यहां पे इंटीजर 0 1 4 16 32
48 64 अब प्रैक्टिकली भी देख लो तो चलो
फिर प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन चुपचाप करते
हैं तो आराम से तो बिल्कुल आप देखते रहो
और खुद से समझते रहो जहां पर डाउट आए
मुझसे पूछ लेना
हम चार वेरिएबल यहां डिक्लेअ कर रहे हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
उसके बाद
ये चार वेरिएबल हमने यहां पर डिक्लेअर
किए। तो सबसे पहले हम स्टार्ट करेंगे
सेट
सेल
ये हो गया देन उसके बाद हम आपको एक कमेंट
मेंशन कर देता हूं
जी
पाथ फॉर स्टोरिंग
एप्लीकेशन सेटिंग्स
नेक्स्ट
क्योंकि कमेंट आपकी सेल एक्सप्लरी है।
आपको बिल्कुल सब कुछ क्लियर समझ में आ
जाएगा।
एच के सी यू यह आपकी
रजिस्ट्री की के पाथ होते हैं जो आपको
पढ़ना पड़ेगा और आपने अगर मेरी प्रीवियस
क्ला देखी हैं तो आपको पता चल जाएगा
क्योंकि रजिस्ट्री के बारे में बता चुका
हूं।
मे बी इसमें डाउट हो सकता है मेरे को एच
के सीयू मैं देख लेता हूं हम
सॉफ्टवेयर के अंदर हम आ गया था म कस्टम ऐप
इसमें है क्या कुछ
कोई नहीं देखते हैं। चलो इसमें होगा या
नहीं होगा। लेट्स ट्राई थीम टी एच ई ए
थीम। ओके
फिर से कमेंट मेंशन करते हैं।
स्टेप वन एंड टू।
दो स्टेप हम करने वाले हैं। क्रिएट एंड
राइट
टू
Windows रजिस्ट्री
उसके बाद नाउ
सेव
डार्क मोड
सेटिंग्स इनू
विंडोज रजिस्ट्री
अब
ओबीजी सेल डॉट आर ए जी डब्लू आर आई टी
उसके बाद
हमें हमें क्या मेंशन करना था वही आपको
पाथ मेंशन करना करना था। ठीक है? तो एस टी
आर
आर ए जी के ई वाई चिम। उसके बाद हमें क्या
मेंशन करना है? वैल्यू मेंशन करनी है। तो
डार्क मोड
टी ए आर के उसके बाद एम ओ जी डार्क मोड।
उसके बाद हमें डेटा टाइप भी मेंशन करना
है। तो डेटा टाइप हम मेंशन करेंगे। आर ई
जी अंडरस्कोर एस जेड स्ट्रिंग के लिए। यह
हम डाटा टाइप हमने मेंशन कर दिया। नेक्स्ट
यहां तक सब कुछ आई होप सब कुछ चल रहा है।
अभी हम नेक्स्ट कमेंट देते हैं। ऑटो
क्लोजिंग
क्लोजिंग पॉप अप
ऑटो क्लोजिंग पॉप अप मतलब
प्रोसेस इन
04 सेकंड।
उसके बाद
तो क्रिएशन प्रोसेस
चलो फिर इंटरल्ट
इंटरल्ट
ओके नेक्स्ट
अभी सेल डॉट पॉप अप
चलो हम यूज़ भी करें डॉट पॉपअप उसके बाद हम
यूज़ करें नेक्स्ट
ऐप सेटिंग
क्रिएटेड
एप सेटिंग क्रिएटेड
एमसेंट
वी बी सी आर एल एफ एमसेंट
उसके बाद फिर
सेटिंग थीम
सेटिंग थीम इक्वल
डार्क मोड
रिटर्न टू रजिस्ट्री
नेक्स्ट 4 सेकंड नेक्स्ट जैसे हमने टाइटल
लिखा
स्टेप वन
क्रिएट एंड
राइट
क्रिएट एंड राइट के बाद हमने लिखा 64 64
क्यों लिखा आपको समझ में आना चाहिए क्यों
लिखा होगा हमने इनेशन के लिए ठीक है पॉप
अप टेक्स्ट मेंशन किया गुड पीबीआर सेटिंग
नेम गुड रिटर्न बाय उसके बाद फोर ये हो
गया। ये आपका पूरा पूरा क्या है? आपका
पहला टेक्स्ट है। उसके बाद जो आप पॉप अप
करवाना चाहते हो उसके बाद नंबर ऑफ सेकंड
के लिए ये सबको समझ में आ गया होगा। आई
होप यहां यहां तक सबको आ रहा होगा ना।
किसी को कोई डाउट आ रहा है बीच में। अगर
किसी को कोई भी डाउट आ रहा है तो प्लीज
पूछ लेना मुझसे।
ओके? कोई भी किसी को डाउट आ रहा है तो
प्लीज पूछ लेना।
नेक्स्ट।
तो स्टेप थ्री करते हैं अभी हम। स्टेप
थ्री में हमें क्या करना है? तो स्टेप
थ्री देख लेते हैं। स्टेप थ्री में क्या
करना है?
कुछ इंडेंटेशन दे दिया ना हमने इसमें।
स्टेप थ्री
रिट्रव द
टर्ड सेटिंग
फ्रॉम
Windows रजिस्ट्री
चलो
टीआर
रीड इन
अभी हम रीड करेंगे। ठीक है तो चलो
डॉट
रीड
एस टी आर
आर ए जी के ई वाई हम इससे अभी रीड कर रहे
हैं। जैसे हमने इसे रीड किया देन उसके बाद
पॉप अप दिखाएंगे। तो चलो फिर पॉप अप कैसे
करना है हमें? ऑब्जेक्ट डॉट पॉपअप
सेल डॉट पॉप अप चलो फिर यहां पर करते हैं
हम ऑब्जेक्ट सेल डॉट पॉप अप
एंड अभी क्या हम डायरेक्टली कर रहे हैं
अभी हम
क्लीन अप
सॉरी सॉरी
स्टेप फोर का लिख दिया था मैंने
रीडिंग फ्रॉम रजिस्ट्री
तुरंत
नाउ स्टेप
अभी हमारा स्टेप फोर है।
क्लीन द रजिस्ट्री
अभी हम रजिस्ट्री को क्लीन करेंगे। ठीक
है? मतलब सारे आपके
चारों के चारों मेथड कवर हो जाएंगे।
समझ में नहीं आ रहा?
नो सर का मतलब क्या समझ में नहीं आया? समझ
में आने के बाद कुछ और मतलब है।
आ रहा है आ रहा है। ओके गुड
उसके बाद फिर से
इसको मैं पूरा कॉपी कर लेता हूं। जो चेंज
करना है वो कर दूंगा मैं इसमें।
एंड यहां पर लिख देते हैं हम
क्लीन अप कंप्लीट।
क्लीन अप कंप्लीट
उसके बाद है
यहां पर लिख देते हैं हम यहां पर। इसके
अलावा
रजिस्ट्री की
इन
हैज़ बीन
डिलीटेड सक्सेसफुली
सक्सेसफुली और उसके बाद हमने स्टेप थ्री
लिख दिया डिलीट
डिलीट उसके बाद नेक्स्ट
यहां पर हमने अभी क्या 48 दिया
तो यहां तक सबको शायद आई होप सबको कोड
क्लियर होगा और अभी
अच्छी बात है। सुबह पढ़े थे तो आपका काम आ
गया। तभी हम कोड को करते हैं रन। देखो ऐप
सेटिंग क्रिएटेड सेटिंग थीम डार्क मोड
रिटर्न टू रजिस्ट्री। देखो ऑटोमेटिकली कर
रहा है रीडिंग द रजिस्ट्री करंट एक्टिव
एक्टिव डायरेक्ट थीम क्लीन अप कंप्लीट
रजिस्ट्री की थीम सेट डिलीटेड सक्सेसफुली
हो गया हो गया देखो मैंने कुछ नहीं किया
फिर से रन कर देता हूं देखो फिर से रन
किया स्टेप वन आया खुद से पॉपअप आया पे
चला जाएगा 4 सेकंड के बाद सेकंड पॉपअप आया
कहीं पे एरर होती तो एग्जीक्यूट नहीं करता
थर्ड पॉपअप आया बस हो गया
हो गया चलो
समझ में आया
अभी समझ में आ गया
एग्जांपल
सबको क्लियर हो गया एग्जांपल
कभी भी किसी को कोई डाउट है तो क्लास में
प्लीज पूछ लीजिए।
आज की क्लास इतनी करेंगे क्योंकि कल की जो
क्लास होगी उसमें हम पढ़ेंगे कंटिन्यू
करेंगे। कल हम फोल्डर क्रिएट करना उसके
अंदर से फाइल मतलब फोल्डर क्रिएट करना रीड
करना सर्च करना ये चीजें हम सीखेंगे। ठीक
है? फोल्डर क्रिएट करना, टेक्स्ट फाइल
क्रिएट करना, एग्जिस्टिंग टेक्स्ट फाइल
ओपन करना, रीड फाइल कंटेंट को रीड करना,
उसके बाद सर्च करना। ये सारी चीजें हम
सीखेंगे किसके अंदर? वीबीए के अंदर कल की
क्लास में। उसके बाद इन सभी का एक कंबाइन
जितना भी अभी तक मैंने पढ़ा कि इसके अंदर
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट के साथ हमने जितना भी
फाइल सिस्टम के साथ इंटरेक्शन है चाहे
आपका रजिस्ट्री के साथ इंटरेक्शन है चाहे
फिर आपका फिर टर्मिनल के साथ इंटरेक्शन का
कंबाइन एक प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे उसके बाद कुछ
दो या दो या तीन सिनेरियोस पे काम करेंगे
ताकि आपकी प्रैक्टिस हो जाए।
हां बिल्कुल नया है जगत गुरु जी इसलिए
छोटे थोड़ा-थोड़ा करवा रहा हूं मैं आप
लोगों को बिल्कुल छोटा-छोटा स्टेप बाय
स्टेप करवा रहा हूं पहले थ्योरी
थ्योरेटिकल बता रहा हूं फिर आपको
प्रैक्टिकल बता रहा हूं ताकि एक-एक चीज
आपको समझ में आ जाए
रियल डॉक्यूमेंट्स में शो देखो मैंने आपको
ये क्या हुआ रजिस्ट्री क्रिएट भी हुई और
डिलीट भी हो गई अगर यहां पर कोई भी इशू
होता तो एरर आता मतलब सक्सेसफुल रजिस्ट्री
राइट भी होगी रीड भी हो गई और डिलीट भी हो
गई। ओके? रजिस्ट्री में सारी चीजें
ऑटोमेटिकली हो गया। तो इसका जब हम कंबाइन
एग्जांपल देखेंगे उसके बाद दो से तीन और
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन देखेंगे जिसमें हम आपको
सारी प्रैक्टिस हो जाएंगी कि ओके कैसे आप
पेलोड बना के मैनुअली उसको हाई हाइड करके
एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हो। उसके बाद फिर हम
देखेंगे एक और वेपनाइजेशन
फिर ड्रॉपर पावर सेल ड्रॉपर। ये चीजें हम
स्टेप बाय स्टेप पढ़ेंगे। तो आपको पूरा
आईडिया हो जाएगा कि आप इस वीबीए पे लोड को
कैसे यूज कर सकते हो। बट फॉर योर काइंड
इंफॉर्मेशन कि यहां पर आपको इवेज टेक्निक
नहीं बताई जा रही। आपको यहां पर एडीआर
बाईपास करने नहीं बताई जा रही है। Windows
डिफेंडर बाईपास करने जाते। ये आपको खुद से
रिसर्च करना होगा। आपको सिर्फ इतना बताया
जा रहा है कि चीजें कैसे काम करती है। आप
उसको कैसे यूज़ कर सकते हैं। बाकी आपको हिट
एंड ट्रायल आपका दिमाग खुद ही लगाना
पड़ेगा। आपकी कॉमन सेंस खुद लगानी पड़ेगी।
आपको बाहर से कोई नहीं बताने वाला। वो चीज
आपको खुद से पढ़नी होगी। उसके लिए आपको
जितनी रिसर्च, जितना सब कुछ आपको फाइंड
आउट करना हो खुद से करना होगा। मेरा काम
है आपको गाइडेंस करना, आपको एक ट्रैक
पकड़ाना। उसके बाद आपको खुद से ही करना
पड़ेगा। क्योंकि कोई भी इंस्ट्रक्टर आपको
YouTube पे तो बिल्कुल ही नहीं पढ़ा सकता
ये चीजें। बाकी भले ही कोई हाई प्रीमियम
क्लासेस लेकर आके, बहुत महंगी क्लासेस
लेकर आके पढ़ा सकता है। बट ये चीजें अब
कोई भी YouTube पे तो नहीं पढ़ाएगा। इवन
मैं भी नहीं पढ़ा सकता। बिकॉज़ ये चैनल ही
बैन हो जाएगा। ऐसा कुछ कर दिया तो
मैं आपको ग्रुप में बुक्स के रेफरेंस दे
सकता हूं। वो आप बुक्स पढ़ोगे तो आपको उन
चीजों की तरफ आप क्या कर सकते हो? मूव ऑन
कर सकते हो।
तो चलिए फिर अगर आपका अभी कोई डाउट है
क्लास से रिलेटेड तो आप मुझसे पूछ सकते
हो। अगर डाउट नहीं है। कोई भी डाउट नहीं
है क्लास से रिलेटेड आपका
देखो मैं एक चीज बताता हूं।
अभी जमाना है एआई का।
ठीक है? याद रखना ही नहीं। आपको बता दिया
कैसे चीजें काम कर रही हैं। आपको याद नहीं
रखना। यह इसलिए था क्योंकि अगर आपको कोई
पेलोड बना बनाया मिलता है या खुद से बनाना
पड़ जाए या आपको एआई बना कर देता है तो
आपको छोटे-मोटे चेंजेस खुद से करने पड़
जाए उसके अंदर तो आप उस कोड को देखकर समझ
जाए कि इस कोड में क्या हो रहा है इस पेड
में और वो आप क्या कर सकते हो उसको खुद से
छोटे-मोटे चेंजज़ कर पाओ समझ पाओ। एआई का
जमाना है। ठीक है? बस आपको दिमाग लगाना
है। एआई आपको डायरेक्ट पेलोड कभी नहीं
देगा। बट आपको दिमाग लगाना है कि चीज आपको
टास्क परफॉर्म आपको क्या करवाना है?
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन करवाना है आपको।
सेम पेलोड बनाना है। पेलोड का आप एक काम
करो ना पेलोड मत यूज़ करो ना शब्द। आपको जो
करना है फॉर एग्जांपल आपका आपको क्या करना
है कि एक फाइल ड्रॉप करनी है सिस्टम के
ऊपर। तो आपको फाइल ड्रॉप करने का एक कोड
चाहिए और उसके अंदर आपको क्या करना है?
चाहे exc करने हो कुछ भी करने हो लेकिन
आपको क्या इंटक्ट करना है पावर सेल के साथ
इंटैक्ट करना है उसके फाइल ड्रॉप करनी है
ड्रॉप करके फाइल को डिलीट भी होनी चाहिए
एग्जीक्यूट होने के बाद तो ऐसा कुछ सोचो
कि आप
एi से वो काम करवा लो बट ऐसे वर्डिंग यूज़
ना हो जिससे उसको लगे कि आप मुझसे कुछ
मिलसियस काम करवाना चाहते हो पेलोड डेवलप
करवाना चाहते हो नहीं मैं एक टीएक्सटी
फाइल ले रहा हूं मुझे क्या करना है किसी
वीबीए के थ्रू टीxt फाइल पावर सेल के थ्रू
इस लोकेशन पे क्या करनी
ड्रॉप करवानी है। ड्रॉप करवाने के बाद
उसको फिर क्या करना है? मैं उसको बाद में
एग्जीक्यूटेबल में बदल सकता हूं। यह कर
सकता हूं। उसके बाद वो करवा के उसको डिलीट
भी करना है। ऐसे कुछ यूज़ करोगे वो समझ
जाएगा। लेकिन इसको भी आपको अच्छे से यूज़
करना है कि आप इसको और बेटर तरीके से कैसे
एआई से पूछ सकते हो ताकि जो एआई है इसको
सस्िशियस डिटेक्ट ना करें। क्योंकि एआई को
लगा कि आप मुझसे कुछ गलत काम करवा रहे हो
तो वो आपको सेम टाइम बोल देगा कि भैया मैं
आपकी हेल्प नहीं कर सकता। इसमें मैं आपको
इतना जरूर बता सकता हूं कि आपको क्या-क्या
करना चाहिए। बट वो आपको कोड डेवलप करने
में हेल्प नहीं करेगा। बट आप अगर सही चीज
उससे करवाओगे तो सही चीज आप करवा लीजिए।
उसके बाद वो सही चीज में खुद से आपको इतनी
नॉलेज मैं आपको दे दूंगा यहां पर वीबीए
कोड लिखने की। आप खुद से उसको लिख सकते
हो। खुद से आप उसमें थोड़े-मोटे चेंजेस
करोगे और आप अपना काम करवा लोगे।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? समझ में आया?
यह चीज सीखनी क्यों जरूरी है? क्योंकि
देखो एआई आपके लिए वेबसाइट बना देगा,
मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन बना देगा। पेलोड कभी
नहीं देगा, एक्सप्लइट कभी नहीं देगा।
बट एक स्ट्रक्चर्स ले लिया आपने उसकी।
स्ट्रक्चर को तो आप खुद से मैनपुलेट कर
लोगे। बिकॉज़ यू आर लिटिल प्रोग्रामर।
तो चलिए फिर
तो एक चीज मुझे बता दीजिए। सबको मेरी आवाज
अच्छे से आ रही थी। आज? ऐसा तो नहीं है कि
आवाज मेरी फट रही थी या आवाज में कुछ कम
आवाज थी। बाकी क्लासेस के कंपेयर में मुझे
एक फीडबैक चाहिए क्योंकि यह एक टेस्टिंग
भी कर रहा हूं क्योंकि कल क्लास मुझे लेनी
है ना तो उसमें ऐसी चीजें मैं नहीं मॉनिटर
कर सकता। क्लियर था? बिल्कुल क्लियर है।
कल में और आज में कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है।
आवाज थोड़ा सा ज्यादा था, कम था कल से।
कल से ज्यादा था।
ओके ओके थैंक यू एवरीवन।
तो चलो फिर कल मिलते हैं सेम टाइम। या अगर
टाइमिंग थोड़ा डिले करना पड़ जाए मुझे किसी
भी कारण से। बिकॉज़ कल मेरी दो क्लासेस हो
जाएंगी। तो प्लीज
थोड़ा सा मेरे साथ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करना। तो कल भी हमारा सेशन
होगा। कंटिन्यू करेंगे। मजा आ रहा है
कंटिन्यू क्लासेस में। मैं आप लोगों के
लिए कंटिन्यू क्लास कर सकता हूं। बट
कंडीशन वही है कि आप लोग क्लास को शेयर
करते नहीं और लोगों को बुलाते नहीं। तो
इसलिए फिर मुझे इंटरेस्ट नहीं आता। ओके?
तो चलिए फिर सी यू फॉर टुमारो। गुड नाइट
एवरीवन। बाय-ब।